in the African rainforests of Congo
National Geographic biologist Mike Fay
runs into a three-ton surprise the
elephant seems more curious than alarmed
until it starts to lumber towards
Michael it flares it's years and
trumpets a warning if it charges Mike he
could easily be crushed so what's the
best way to avoid its lethal assault
should he run between its legs turn and
run away or scream and yell according to
Mike Fay the correct answer is C scream
and yell once you're engaged you do not
show your back to that elephant you do
not turn you do not run because if you
do he will chase you
they're very fast they're stealth you
can easily if he really wants to he can
catch up teeth and you just don't want
to run away the probability of getting
killed is much lower if you stand your
ground than if you run
and yell louder and louder and louder
and I know who was more nervous me or
her